Speaker 1: All right, so yesterday,
after the big Biden Putin summit,
former President Donald Trump appeared on Sean
Hannity's Fox News program to deliver, I guess,
what was billed as analysis of Joe Biden's meeting
with the Russian president, Vladimir Putin, that
we talked about earlier. It took place in Geneva,
Switzerland, and it was really pathetic. And in
some sense, it was almost kind of sad. A Trump
desperate for relevance, relegated to opining
about how the guy who defeated him easily did
during a summit with a guy, Vladimir Putin,
who walked all over Donald Trump
during Trump's presidency. Now,
whoa, hold on a second, everybody. Take
it easy. I'm not saying Trump and Putin
ever got together to plan anything. I'm not saying
I want a war with Russia. I don't I just I've got
to be clear, because otherwise that sort of Putin
loving segment of the audience will come after me.
But let's check out some of these clips. And Trump
is just so jealous of Joe Biden and the fact that
Biden just kind of behaved normally during the
summit like the summit was no big success other
than it was a normal summit and it was a return
to kind of standard diplomacy. And the interview
with Hannity very quickly went completely
off the rails. Trump Now, just this isn't
even related to Putin. Trump just doing openly
anti vax talking points. Now, listen to this.
Speaker 6: And now we have to get back into
the schools, have to get open. And frankly,
we're lucky we have the vaccine. But
the vaccine on very young people is
something that you got to really stop. You have
to get back to running your country. I mean,
Speaker 1: what is he talking about? Schools
basically are open and it's also summer for
some school districts already. And
everybody's going to be back in the fall.
Most schools already opened and vaccines on young
people. We have to stop vaccines on young people.
We haven't even started vaccines on young people.
Pfizer is approved for twelve plus. Otherwise,
there's nothing else that we're starting to test
the vaccine now. We're testing it safely. It
appears to be very safe. These are just straight
up anti vaccine talking points now from Trump,
who, by the way, wants credit for the vaccine,
which is really dangerous for children,
even though there's not actually evidence of that.
Speaker 6: See reasons.
And I am a big believer in what we did
with the vaccine preventable, what we did.
Speaker 1: Trump is the winner for doing
the vaccine, but it's a very dangerous
one for children. And we've got to stop
giving it to them, which we're not yet,
until it's tested and appear safe.
Speaker 6: You see the results. But
to have every school child where it's
ninety nine point nine nine percent,
they just don't you know, they're
just not affected or affected badly.
Having to receive a vaccine, I
think, is something that you and
Speaker 1: of course, nobody has to receive it
unless you eventually if it becomes a requirement
to go to school, as has been the case for other
vaccines, the parents would get to choose.
I want my kid in this school. And so I will do
the required vaccinations to attend, of which,
if covid-19 is added, would not be the only
vaccine. Or you can opt not to go there. But
nobody is being forced to vaccinate. We don't
have to stop vaccines on kids because we haven't
even started them yet. It's it's all wild. In this
next clip, Hannity cuts Trump off when he starts
a completely unhinged rant about wind turbines.
Speaker 6: Again, it may get windmills all over
the place to ruin our land and
kill our birds, kill everything
Speaker 1: and windmills are
killing everything. Guys,
the windmills that they're killing, everything are
Speaker 6: going to be and they're very
intermittent as you learn from watching
over the last four months. It's intermittent
energy. Yeah, it's not good. It's not
going to power our great factories
and it's terrible. What did you make of them?
Speaker 4: Yeah, there was a question of what?
There was a question of whether Ukraine
would join NATO and Biden's answer,
Speaker 1: man, that is just good hands like
this is the windmills. Killing everybody is
not a great direction to go in for Hannity's
program. So Hannity tries to derail that. Then
Trump is still calling the 1918 flu, the 1917 flu.
Speaker 6: And if we weren't successful, show it.
I'll tell you this. You would have another 1917
tragedy where almost 100 million people died.
Speaker 1: Yep, still calling it
that. Still calling it the 1917 flu.
Trump then in the midst of this, wanting to
go back to talk about Hillary and Hannity is
actually helping him do it. Take a look at this.
Speaker 4: We know that Hillary Clinton paid for
the dirty Russian misinformation dossier that
even Christopher Steele doesn't stand by and
the sub source doesn't stand by.
Speaker 1: Right. And then it
wasn't just Hannity doing it, but Trump also
insisting on going back and talking a. About
Comey and McCabe, and they just will not stop
Speaker 6: the big gun
and I'm talking about very, very serious things,
if you look at Comey and McCabe and the two lovers
and all of the things that went on and they
weren't prosecuted, if you read the Horowitz
report and of course, everyone still waiting
for Durham. What happened to Durham and how is
that allowed to go into another administration? By
the way? Is he in the witness protection program?
Speaker 4: I'd like to know where he is
to he in the witness protection program.
Speaker 1: So really touching on the issues of the
day. Remember Trump invited on to analyze as if
Trump could analyze anything. Trump invited on to
analyze the Putin Biden summit and doing anti vax
doing the 1917 flu. Doing what about Peter Struck
and his lover page or whatever her name was.
Trump. Then again, completely delusional, claiming
that an endorsement from him is stronger than
anything else anybody could ever even imagine.
Speaker 6: So I'm very honored to say that my
endorsement means more than any endorsement
that has ever been given by anybody. I mean,
you know, I'm there.
Speaker 1: I don't know
exactly what he's talking about. Trump became
president. Republicans then lost the House
in twenty eighteen, lost the Senate in 2020 and
lost the White House in 2020. And Trump wants
us to believe his endorsements are really, really
strong. Of course, no Trump interview is complete
until he again, sort of references I
didn't really lose and I may be back soon.
Here he is doing that.
Speaker 4: You ever
considered it and are you considering it?
Speaker 6: Well, I am. And frankly,
if you think of it, that's what I've been doing
and talking about for a long time. And I guess
that's why we got them by surprise. And 16 and
in 20, we did much better than we did in 16. And
shockingly, we were supposed to win easily and
64 million votes and we got seventy five million
votes and we didn't win. But let's see
what happens on that whole thing is
Speaker 1: let's see, because Trump
could be back absolutely any day
and still still sort of floating that and
signaling his followers. And then lastly here,
Hannity throws a complete softball to Trump about
if you run in twenty twenty four, what will you
do differently? And Trump just he can't keep
it together. He talks about the Clintons and
fake investigations and all sorts of wacky stuff.
Speaker 4: Is there anything and we have a minute
left. If you do run in twenty twenty four. Right.
What might you do differently? What do you know
now that you didn't know in twenty sixteen.
Speaker 6: Well, you know, we ran a very
successful administration where the
greatest economy in history we had
one hundred and sixty million jobs. We were never
even close to that. No, nobody was ever even close
to that. And we did it twice because then we did
it after the pandemic. We came up with a vaccine.
We did a lot of great things and we did it after.
But I was under siege with fake investigations and
everything. And I was doing this while I was under
siege from phony people with phony Russia, Russia,
Russia that was caused by the
Speaker 1: people were fake.
That's that's interesting. We've known
he thinks the investigations were fake,
but the people doing them were fake to
Speaker 6: Clinton and the DNC,
Democrats and all of that. And we did it.
We build space for us. We did. You know,
we did. We rebuilt the military. We
got the largest tax cut in history,
the largest regulation cuts in history.
Speaker 1: I'm pretty sure everything he's
saying is a lie. They weren't the biggest tax
cuts in history. He did cut some regulations, but
unfortunately, he didn't cut that many,
but not they were damaging the cuts. But
I don't think anything he's saying here
is true. Nothing none of it closed.
Speaker 6: We did end war, which they've
already excluded, thanks to Murkowski in Alaska.
And, you know, Hannity rapping.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So, I mean, just an incredible,
incredible, bizarre interview. And my question
continues to be, can anybody tell me specifically
what was the massive failure of the Biden Europe
trip that every right winger is ranting about?
They say it was a failure, but they don't mention
what the failure was. They don't have anything
specific to mention. They just want to create this
atmosphere that it was terrible. And then the Fox
viewers just repeat it, but they never can explain
what was the failure. And also, don't forget what
happened in the Putin Trump summit in Helsinki
in July of twenty eighteen, where the whole
question was, is Trump going to confront Putin
about Russia's meddling in the 2016 election?
And Trump came out and when he was asked about
it, said, I hope both countries responsible,
partially blaming the U.S. if there was
Russian meddling, which he won't say there was,
it's partially the US's fault. And then he also
said, listen, Putin denied it, Putin denied it,
and he seemed sincere in his denial. So everybody
just runs around Trump. Trump met with Kim Jong.
And he thought he got incredible concessions
from Kim Jong un, didn't realize these are the
concessions that they always make and never
stick to Trump thought it was a big victory.
Trump meets with Putin and he says, I don't know
Putin. He was pretty convincing. And it's like,
this is what Putin does. This Putin is the
slick guy Trump wishes he could be. And
Trump fell for that. And it's just all humiliating
and embarrassing. And Joe Biden's not perfect or
anything close to it, but it is good to be beyond
the insanity of foreign policy under Trump.